teror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on radio
and on your smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PG on censored outrage as
Oprah Winfrey admits she's taking
controversial weight loss drugs after
telling her millions of fans she never
dream of doing it is she Hollywood's
biggest hypocrite and can we ever trust
her again we'll
debate also tonight should you boycott
Piers Morgan yes me that hashtag has
been trending all week after my
controversial interview with an NHS
doctor accused of supporting Hamas Well
he kind of admitted it one of my
fiercest critics joins me in the
studio and could President Biden be
impeached Fox newsstar Brian Kil me
joins me to discuss a torrid week for
America's first
[Music]
family from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Pi Morgan
uncensored Oprah winf has enjoyed a long
and story career in the media Spotlight
most recently probably best known for
performatively gaping at Harry and
Megan's bogus claims of racism in one of
the most poorly researched and
challenged interviews in television
history there's a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to
be well there's now a conversation an
awkward conversation between Oprah
Winfrey and her own fans after Miss she
been telling them giant Whoppers about
her weight Oprah's long since railed
against the use of medication for weight
loss she's a poster girl as a body
positivity movement which basically
argues you can celebrate being as fat as
you like while simultaneously making a
cottage industry of her own yo-yoing
weight well recently she's been spotted
looking decidedly spelt on the red
carpets and she couldn't wait to tell
her many followers that she'd done it
all the hard way and they could too I've
got to do it the hard way I've got to
keep climbing the mountains I got to
keep suffering I got to do that because
otherwise I somehow cheated myself even
when I first started hearing about the
weight loss drugs at the same time I was
going through knee surgery and I felt
I've got to do this on my own I've got
to do this on my own because if I take
the drug that's the easy way
out yeah unfortunately that was the easy
way out because it wasn't true it was
all very inspiring that rhetoric but
that wasn't what was going on a new
confessional Interview With People
magazine this week Oprah revealed she's
been using the very weight loss drug she
said she' never used most likely a zenic
I've released my own Shame about it she
says I now use it as I feel I need it
fact there's a medically approved
prescription for managing weight and
staying healthier in my life time feels
like relief like Redemption like a gift
not something to hide behind and once
again be ridiculed for I'm absolutely
done with the shame me from other people
and particularly myself Opa revealed she
took the medication and the build up to
Thanksgiving because in her work she
knew she was going to have to two to two
solid weeks of eating so having lectured
her fans as a global face of Weight
Watchers about the importance of hard
work and not cheating and not taking
these drugs she was actually secretly
already taking them and these of course
a diabetes trucks and express purpose of
this is so that she could presumably get
through Thanksgiving fortnite and not
worry about it well this is important
because Opa Winfrey commands Legions of
followers who do as she tells them to do
and bu buy what she tells them to buy
and act as she tells them to act she's
given the green light for millions of
people to stop exercising now and to
stuff their faces and take the pills and
let's not forget that Oprah is also a w
worldwide Pioneer for the concept of my
truth speaking your truth is the most
powerful tool we all
have it is and once again we remind
exactly what my truth is it's that
phrase that celebrities use when they
want to lie to their back teeth and not
tell the actual truth because they think
it's okay just to be feeling something
even if it's the opposite to what
they're actually doing the truth is that
Oprah Winfrey deliberately pedal a lie
to her fans and today they're all
reacting in exactly the same way as
me
what yeah well for reaction to that I'm
joined by the author of the case for
Council culture Ernest Owens and
professor of clinical medicine the Fox
News contributor Dr Mark seagull well
welcome to you both um Dr seagull let me
start with you if I may I think you're
at the heart of this just lies a really
horrible conceit which is that Oprah
Winfrey went out there in September and
and proudly said look I'm I'm losing all
this weight the hard way the hard yards
way this I want to touch those drugs
that's not for me you shouldn't do that
and now it turns out that as she was
saying that she was taking these drugs
yeah I I'm very disturbed about this for
a lot of reasons Piers first of all back
in 1988 she supposedly lost 67 pounds
with dietary change and exercise as
you've already said she had the B body
positivity movement she was a big leader
in that that said accept people as you
are now she's out talking about the the
shaming got to me the fat shaming got to
me well what about for people out there
that don't that it didn't get to that
already listened to her before for and
said they're going to accept themselves
as they are now she says this pill is a
Redemption what is it a spiritual or a
religious pill instead of going to
church or synagogue you take this pill
and you're redeemed she's also talking
about being on it as a maintenance drug
well I'm a physician who prescribes this
I don't like the word maintenance how
long is she going to stay on it these
drugs have side effects there was 3,000
calls to poison centers in the United
States last year from people who didn't
know how to dose it properly it comes in
a very set dose one more thing there's a
huge run on this drug it's not
stigmatized anymore so if she thinks
she's coming out as a celebrity to beat
the stigma it's not stigmatized there's
a huge run on it and diabetics can't get
it yeah I think that's a hugely
important part of this all right Ernest
Owens here's the problem I've know opra
a long time she did the first interview
uh when I I I launched a show at CNN and
she was very gracious to me in that and
very open but she Prides herself always
on being completely honest not least
with her fans and whether you like her
or not or support her or not she's been
here clearly dishonest to her fans
hasn't
she no I don't think so I think she's
evolved on the issue and if you actually
read that interview and really thought
about how she came to a place of how she
wanted to choose this decision it's up
to her it's her body it's her choice I
find it quite interesting that a bunch
of men are debating on whether or not
she's authentic as a black woman on she
chooses to treat her body got to do with
their skin color interest well who
mentioned their skin
color I did I mean you you've mentioned
other skin colors
before I'm saying that it's you thr me
there we're talking about weight loss
we're talking about people's skin colors
okay but you're also talking but have
you ever talked about men's weight loss
on this show Pier
yes who
me you me and so what was your decision
what was your weight loss Journey about
what I didn't do is lie to the public I
said you know what here's how you lose
weight you've put less stuff in your Gob
you eat less you drink less you exercise
a bit more you'll lose weight or you go
or you can go on a z which is a cheat
which is a cheat used by diabetics and
it will work but as the doctor say we
don't know the side effects blah the
point
is Li what she does with her body but
Earnest she lied that's the point well
but I don't I don't consider her lying I
think that she's evolved on the issue
and I think the reality is you should
hold Grace for people who evolve on
their thinking of the matter she
expresses that she's giv herself a
little bit more grace that she's being
more kind to herself that we have to be
realize that we're in a society where
high-profile celebrities specifically
women are often times in society where
they feel like they have to do all types
of things to their bodies in order to
feel how they feel I think Oprah made
the decision that works for her that's
her choice that's her agency and we
should respect all right Dr
SE Piers yeah I want to jump in here
because I noticed first of all I respect
Ernest a lot but I noticed he didn't
mention the word physician once in there
let's remember this is a prescription
drug it isn't that that even Oprah
doesn't get to decide a physician has to
prescribe this and unfortunately there's
way too way too many ways you can get
this on tele medicine without a real
physician and doctors have to discern
and I'm telling you there's a tremendous
shortage here so when a celebrity like
her who's hu got a huge following huge
Following comes out like this late in
the game not early in the game puts even
more pressure on the situation where I
can't use the drug for people who need
it the most that's my issue I completely
agree that that is a very serious we
don't know all the details we don't know
all the details of Oprah's health and at
the end of the day she's a very smart
woman she's a very wealthy woman and she
has the resources to inform herself on
her own personal choices with her body
and so I think that will be intellect
she dishonest to act as though she's
just rogely getting this you know drug
and not thinking about all the
precautions and measures I think she's
you know what I think Ernest I admire
your efforts to try and defend her but I
think you're defending the indefensible
the truth is she lost so much weight I
know Sharon Osborne very well great
friend of mine she talked recently about
how she lost way too much weight with a
Zen piic and is now desperately trying
to put it back on that's a problem for a
lot of people I've seen right and
Sharon's been very open about
that Oprah's lost so much weight so far
she couldn't keep lying that she was
doing it the hard way by yumping and
hiking in the Hills she wasn't she was
taking a drug that stops you having an
appetite she stopped eating because she
was taking a zenic that's the truth and
as the doctor seagull said with with so
many people now following her they're
all going to go out and want to do this
because they think wow it worked for
Oprah it's going to work for me but but
but shaming but but using a profile and
a platform like this to shamer speaks
into the same reason why a lot of people
do not disclose how they go through
their weight loss journey and that's
actually fueling to the point that Oprah
was making erest how about doing it
honestly I mean Dr seagull I think I
mean opr
wi how do you how do you get to Define
how a person can honestly lose weight
you say that no no no no that's not what
I said I don't think in mid September in
mid September over win told the world I
am doing it the hard way I'm not going
to touch those drugs now turns out she
was lying maybe that was the way she
chose to do it
then in her interview that she has
changed her perspective she is being sof
all right don't that there's an
evolution here that she has that she's
gr listen listen I don't think I Ernest
Ernest Ernest you made a good point here
that I want to agree with she it's a
personal matter we don't know what her
and her doctor are discussing but she's
coming out as a celebrity here and she's
she's voicing a huge uh as a leader and
the what again the word I don't don't
like his maintenance cuz as Piers is
actually hinting at she's already
looking great and if she stops it you
know the weight's going to come back we
have a huge problem as doctors here what
do we do with this drug people are on it
they can't get off it they try to stop
it the weight comes back this is not
something that that she should be on a
Podium with in my opinion what she does
for her health is between her and her
doctor yeah and by the way let remind
everyone that Oprah is an ambassador for
white Watchers more than a million new
members joined in one year because of
her um she makes gazillions from her 10%
stake in the company uh and Weight
Watchers last time I checked it's not
about taking a drug called a zenic
Ernest again like I've said before there
are various Journeys and various ways
that one can lose weight some people
might feel like they need OIC to help
them with their Journey for various
reasons that we do not know right but
other people will choose to use Weight
Watchers and I think we need to give
Oprah the grace the space and respect
we don't have we're out of it we can't
we can't find it it's not Ines we're out
of it so now people that are morbidly
obese can't get there you what's going
to happen absolute absence ofest a final
point on this you can take this to the
bank and Dr seagull hinted at this the
truth is there's a runon asmic and these
other drugs like it
diabetics hang on let me finish
diabetics are going to end up not being
able to get the crucial drugs they need
because Winfrey fans are going to go out
in their hundreds of thousands and now
try and emulate her weight loss using
this drug and there right there is the
problem Dr seagull great to have you on
uncensor tonight thank you Ernest always
good to have you on even if you're
normally defending the indefensible
thank
you thank you on S next Israel's
ambassador to the UK emphatically
rejects a two-state solution is there
any Prospect of peace or Benjamin netan
who remains prime minister his senior
advisor Mark regev joins me
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I'm like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a f or a
tragedy the ount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin Sullivan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass talking
for liit if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC mous man MC
Mouse man MC M man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party hi
off kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yeah s going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to a rational I've asked you
two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love purgy we can agree
on
[Music]
that welcome back to un sensed Israel's
Ambassador the UK has emphatically
rejected any Prospect of a two-state
solution here's what she told Sky News
is Mark
Austin is there still a chance for a two
State solution I think it's about time
for the world to realize the Oslo
Paradigm failed on the 7th of October
and we need to build a new one and in
order to build a new does that new one
include the Palestinians living in a
state of their own is that what think
the biggest question is what type of
Palestinians are in the other side this
what Israel
realized the answer is absolutely no
well her comments followed a start
Warning by President Biden that Israel's
indiscriminate bombing as he put it in
is weakening international support and
the Prime Minister netanyahu's
right-wing government is making the
prospect of Peace increasingly
impossible joining me now is Mart reg
senior revisor to the Israeli Prime
Minister Mr R thank you very much indeed
for joining us again just start first of
all if we could with um Israel's
ambassador of the UK hotelli coming out
very strongly in this interview with sky
in which she said there's there's no
Prospect of any two-state solution and
that's gone around the world um do you
agree with that I mean is is that it
that's that's down is that Israel's
position now well we're obviously not
close to peace at the moment we're
fighting a war against Kamas and uh
we're focused on winning that war but in
a long-term arrangement we have a
formula that is uh simple and it works I
believe and that formula is as follows
the Palestinians should have all the
rights all the capabilities to govern
themselves and they shouldn't have the
powers that can hurt or threaten Israel
I think that's a sensible formula so
they shouldn't have their own
State well it depends how you define the
term State I'll give you a should they
have the same rights as Israel for
example well I'll ask you the following
question peers should the Palestinians
if they have a state should they be able
to sign let's say a military agreement
uh military treaty with Iran should they
be able to have an army an Air Force
should they have all those military
powers that could theoretically threaten
the state of Israel and the answer in
our view is clearly no why should they
be
prohibited my my question would be why
should they be prohibited from having
exactly the same rights as a state to
Israel wouldn't that be ultimately the
way you actually achieve peace not
allowing the Palestinians to have the
same rights as Israelis has just not
worked has it I mean demonstrably not
worked on the country if this is going
to work it has to be based on realism we
can't base peace on assumptions that
just aren't based founded on reality and
Yak Rabin the prime minister of Israel
who wanted to make peace with the
Palestinians who's was the prime
minister at the time of the signing of
the Oslo Accords he gave a speech and he
was very clear he said that the
Palestinians will have less than a state
yrain said the man who was shot for his
efforts to move forward on the peace
process he said that the future
Palestinian areas will have to be
demilitarized he said that Jordan Valley
that area on the Eastern edge of the
Palestinian territories would have to
remain under Israeli control the idea
that a Palestinian area will have to be
demilitarized in any future uh
settlement that's common
sense and it's been reported and the
Ambassador said yesterday the same
figure that uh the Israeli Defense
Forces so far killed 7,000 Hamas
terrorists uh do you agree is that the
figure that you think is correct and if
so again I think I've asked you this
before how do you
know well this is what our our
intelligence is telling us this is more
or less the figure we've been hitting
Kamas and we've been hitting their
military machine very uh hard and we
will continue to do so until we've
dismantled their military machine and
taken out their top command structure
how many civilians have you
killed well one again that number is
we're relying here on on Hamas numbers
we don't want to see a single civilian
killed do you know that Piers well what
do your intelligence tell you if it's so
sure about the number of Hamas that have
been killed how many civilians have been
killed you must have the same
intelligence
surely I I I agree but I told you I
wasn't sure of the first number either
we're working on approximations what I
can tell you as a matter of policy is we
want to keep the number of Civilian
casualties to the bare minimum but we
Face an enemy that deliberately wants to
see those numbers rise because they see
that as a way to pressure the world to
pressure Israel for a ceasefire because
that's the lifeline for Hamas we are
destroying Hamas peers in the north
we're seeing more and more Hamas
terrorists surrender you've seen
pictures today from a particular
hospital where we saw 70 Kamas Fighters
come out with their weapons above their
heads and surrender to the IDF but what
we're also saying if I may if I may just
pick you up on that're also seeing the
president of the United States your
biggest Ally coming out and saying that
Israel is using indiscriminate bombing
now that is a breach of international
law he's basically accusing you of
committing war
crimes so we are not carpet bombing the
Gaza Strip we are not indiscriminately
targeting why does America's president
think you are well I think the people
who are familiar with the information
know that we have a rigorous process of
Target are you saying he's not getting
good enough
intelligence I I I don't know because
his remarks weren't recorded they were
just reported and I don't know exactly
how he said it or in what context but I
do know he used the phrase
indiscriminate bombing and as you know
that is a war crime if that is the case
that is that is that is not correct that
is not correct Israel does not
indiscriminately bomb Gaza you can
actually see the pictures you see a
house that is standing next to a house
that has been destroyed when there's a
Kamas Target we go after that Target we
do not I repeat do not indiscriminately
bombing Gaza CNN has reported today that
40 to
55% of the 29,000 air to ground
Munitions uh used by Israel have been
unguided dumb bombs uh which have a lack
of precision and therefore expose a much
higher threat to civilians in densely
populated areas is that figure
correct no first of all I would reject
the the the the use of the term Dum
bombs there are different types of
Munitions but but and we don't Target a
a a facility we don't Target a site
unless there is clear intelligence that
there is a Kamas Target that needs to be
taken out I want to stress that again
and again and again we have rules of
stages that must be U must be met before
we target before we use Munitions
there's there's a process of
identification of intelligence analysis
of then a discussion what is the correct
Munitions for that particular Target and
only then will we act to destroy the
target uh new British foreign secretary
David Cameron former prime minister of
course has come out today and said that
extremist settlers by targeting and
killing Palestinian civilians it means
on the West Bank are undermining
security and stability for both Israelis
and Palestinians Israel must take
stronger action to stop settle of
violence and hold the perpetrators
accountable we are Banning this is the
UK those responsible for settle of
violence from entering the UK to make
sure our country cannot be a home for
people who commit these intimidating
acts strong words Sir Mr Cameron your
response well we we we're as a
government we're opposed to any sort of
vigilante violence and we will arrest
people who are involved in it from our
point of view anyone who who acts that
way is acting against the law and we'll
bring the justice system down against
them we'll make arrests and people will
go to jail but I think it must be said
that if one looks on the violence in the
West Bank and of course we condemn and
we act against vigilante Jewish violence
but the overwhelming majority of the
violence 99% of it is in the other
direction and that has to be it has to
be put in
perspective do your intelligence figures
what do they tell you in terms of number
of is Israelis killed on the West Bank
by Palestinians since October the 7th
and conver a number of number of
Palestinians killed by Israelis so first
of all we had that terrible attack in
Jerusalem just last week which you'll
recall I just wonder whether you know
what the the relative figures are no no
we've taken out many more Kamas
terrorists because what we've tried to
do over the last few weeks since this
crisis Kamas didn't operate on the West
Bank i' we've been repeatedly peers of
course it does peers of course they
operate on the West Bank they're not the
government on the West Bank the where
they are in Gaza so what are theas cells
you have Kamas cells across the West
Bank right but what are the numbers Mr
how many Palestinians have died on the
West Bank since the start of this and
how many Israel I can't give you a
figure I I didn't bring that to the
interview and I apologize maybe you have
a figure for me I just know that it's
it's I don't have the precise numbers
but I know it's massively higher number
of Palestinian it is but that but once
again we're not talking about civilians
we're not talking about uninvolved
people we're of civilians Kamas
terrorists disagree we are being as
surgical listen as you know I've always
said Israel has a right to defend itself
after what happened I stand by that the
proportionality of that response I think
is becoming increasingly concerning to
everybody including the American
president um but I think on the West
Bank it is inarguable that the behavior
of these settlers the extremist settlers
is completely out of control now and
surely you would see that that is aside
from everything else that is the least
justifiable part of all of this isn't it
but I'm not justifying it neither is the
government of Israel where if people are
acting in a vigilante way the state will
act against them they'll be arrested and
they'll go through the courts and if
they've committed crimes they'll go to
jail there's no excuse for it no one's
justifying it all I'm saying to you is
the government of Israel acts firmly
against extremist violence but to be
fair I can ask you does the Palestinian
Authority on the West Bank do they act
against their extremist violence and the
answer is no you know we're talking
where where're what is it we're close to
70 days since the October 7th Massacre
and the Palestinian Authority the
so-called moderates have yet to condemn
that terrible atrocious attack against
civilians that's the difference we
condemn extremism we fight extremism
what do they do last time you came on I
asked you whether we could have an
interview with prime minister Netanyahu
he's not given one yet to any European
television network as far as I'm aware
outside of Israel and uh and he's also
talked to American networks I ask you
again will he come and talk to
us I I have to tell you he hasn't done
an interview at all since we spoke last
so don't feel discriminated against
peers he hasn't done a single interview
uh when he starts doing other interviews
again your name will come up thank you
Mr rer thank you very much indeed
appreciate it my pleasure
sir we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well do
you know what I love about talk today we
do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the ref referendum that he
said he would deliver the tor's love a
scrap you can almost see this coming
around the tracks with sella bravman
she's heading up one side and rishy soon
at the other the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swearing off in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong expected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's about Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this is
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group
possible have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV now should you boycott Pi Morgan
that's me of course a number of people
seem to think so online the hashtag has
been trending all week pushed by several
high-profile
Muslims and pro Palestinian accounts as
despite the show in my opinion doing
more to give a platform to Pro
Palestinian voices since this War Began
than any other probably in the
world end the blockade the end the
aparte the end the occupation the the
the notion that Israel is defending
itself is as absurd as the notion that
the rapist is defending itself from the
victim that's a big charge to make about
well he he has just lied before getting
any evidence dealing with Israel is so
difficult it's like being in a
relationship with a narcissistic
psychopath one man's terrorist is a n
man's Freedom Fighter have you never
heard that Palestinians are
just numbers they are not numbers they
are
human well despite this the campaign
against he's been led by the a Institute
and backed by several prominent voices
in the community here's what lawyer
Muhammad akuni the former lawyer of Isis
bride shamima beum had to say the fellow
is just acting like a petulant child he
might as well frankly interview himself
self with a mirror on his show at this
point absolutely no manners behaves
appallingly It's actually an
embarrassment so until unless he can
demonstrate that he knows now how to
interview people with a bit of good
manners and Grace then uh I just don't
want to hear it anymore I suggest
everyone boycot him well tonight I
thought I'd face this boycott headon in
uncensored Style with as much good grace
and manners as I can must joining me to
discuss this is a deputy editor of
Muslim News website five pillar Dilly
hin which has written and spoken a lot
about this week about why Muslims should
be boycotting me so Mr Hussein thank you
for joining me why should I be boycotted
my my position is as I've just shown
with that mashup genuinely genuinely do
not think there's a television news show
in the world that has given a more
consistent or bigger platform to Pro
Palestinian voices and honestly the only
interviews that have got fractures have
come when I've asked the question do you
view Hamas as terrorist you can demn
what they did on October the 7th and if
people prevaricate then I have got angry
because I just think that's
non-negotiable to their credit many pro
Palestinian voices haven't tried to do
that they've accepted it was an
appalling terrorist attack and then we
move on to often very civilized debate
but you know if you can't assess what
happened then for what it clearly was I
I have a problem with that now I just
think overall I don't get the boycott
why would you want to stop people
watching a show that has so many voices
giving your side of this story is our
segment going to be as courteous as the
one you just did with Mark reg you think
that was courteous I think it was
courteous and respectful yeah do you
think we can have that engagement do you
think I asked him good questions you G
but you gave him enough time to answer
without inter you know what I think
about m r he's always very respectful to
me he answers the questions you may not
agree with the answer all your questions
but when people come on Jeremy Corbin
the doctor earlier this week when people
come on and simply won't give a yes or
no answer to a yes or no question that
also can be aggravating you know I don't
look sometimes I get a bit intemperate
sometimes I do get a bit emotional about
stuff it's an emotional story right you
want to use this opportunity to
apologize to one billion Muslim women no
why is that because it was completely
misconstrued because he was in response
to the whole Li um filth conf it right
so the context of my question was that
if you want to treat women in the way
that this member of his organization why
was that your instinctive response
because I felt that that quote was so
disgusting that one of his own group had
talked about needing to get rid of a
secular law bring in Sharia law so he
could get rid of LGBT filth and feminist
filth and then the first reaction of a
doct was say I agree and I was like
really that's how you want to treat
women you want to treat women as
feminist filth now it got clipped up
purely as me saying what you want them
to be oppressed that wasn't what I said
I don't think actually anyone who
watched the whole thing seen your
monologue people have seen your
monologue yeah yeah they've seen your
clarification and and they're still and
it's still trending yes because the
original clip was so misleading it made
out that I think all women who are
Muslims are oppressed or all those who
want to become Muslims would be heading
towards oppression I don't feel that so
you don't want to so you don't want to
apologize to those Muslim women who were
offended no I want to apologize to
anybody who watched the clip that was
put out and was and listen and in my
view was deliberately misled but let's
get to sh Lord you hate Sharia law I
don't hate Sharia law you said you said
you know about Sharia law so what
credentials I know I know that Sharia
law operates in a number of countries
around the world and I know that in
someone like Afghanistan the women who
under Sharia law imposed by the Taliban
are deeply oppressed would you agree
with that what qualifications talk about
would you agree with that what qualific
would you agre have what qualifications
do you have let's trying to reach points
of agreement do you agree that the way
the Taliban treats women is oppression I
want to I'm going to answer your
question can you answer it I I will
answer you question we'll answer it I
want to know why don't answer
supplementary first answer my question
you said you know about Sharia law I I
just asked you a specific question just
want to know what your credentials are
speak about this I'm just asking you
about the situation in Afghanistan there
with a Taliban interpretation and
implementation of sharia law in my
opinion and the opinion of most people
outside of Afghan who's most people well
I'm about to ask you whether you agree
with it do you think the way women are
treated in Afghanistan by the Taliban
there are aspects is oppression or not
there are aspects of misapplication of
no education there's
an P we we're going that road again
aren't we well you tell me I've just
said to you there are misapplication of
sharia law not just in Afghanistan
across the B is the Taliban misapplying
it I'm asking you what is your expertise
to comment on this Sor it's my show I do
the question but you invited me I'm just
asking you a question you haven't
answered it is the Taliban implementing
sh Laur accurately or not not entirely
and comprehensively okay so we can agree
that there there is oppression of women
there is most certain aspects to reform
and review in the education system of
Afghanistan would you would you say the
way women are treated in Afghanistan
right Now by Taliban is oppressive I
don't appreciate this line of
questioning peace of course you don't
cuz you know why you know why someone
will clip up you say Taliban are
oppressing women and before you know it
Dilly you will be trending worldwide
everyone will go wow Dilly Hussein says
Muslim women are oppressed this you see
how easy it is to this type of question
what makes people think you are Islam
yeah this is why you want to boycott me
because you don't want me asking
difficult questions got nothing to do
with a J you don't want me asking
difficult questions so the reason why
people are calling for your boycott is
because you offended 1 billion Muslim
women didn't yes you did no yes why why
is it trending okay as I've just said to
you I could stand by I can now clip up
you criticizing the Talib wait
criticizing the way Taliban treat women
under Sharia law I could clip just that
bit of you stammering and looking
awkward and conceding it's not right
right and then before you know it it
becomes Dilly Hussein wax the Taliban
this is wrong women are being oppressed
blah blah blah and you'll sit there
going hang on but that's how it works
it's misleading it's deliberate
agonistic I don't have form you have
form no I don't you have form no I don't
you want to give me the example you want
give the example I'll give you let me
give you a better example let's go back
to 2003 when this country my country
launched an illegal invasion of Iraq
okay right who stood up then right for
Iraqis who stood up for innocent people
in Iraq and launched the biggest media
campaign against the British government
in modern times me okay right do you
know that do you remember that do you
give me any credit for that or do you
look at me as the Muslim basher
because I'm not and you know I'm not so
we going back to 2003 why don't we talk
about 2019 why don't we talk about you
went back first no the fact that you
have no qualifications to talk about
Jihad you don't even have a primary
principles basis to talk about no
quations I've been a journalist for 35
years I've had to cover I've had to
cover this for 35 years and you never
POS these such questions to any of your
Israeli guests about why L just heard me
10 minutes ask questions Netanyahu and
Senior diplomat who have used Biblical
verses biblical vers ofik to carry out
genocide have you questioned anyone
about that did you watch my show last
night did you question did you watch my
show last night no I didn't okay you
wouldn't have seen Norman finlin then
for half an hour talking exactly about
that I'm talking about yourself
questioning your guests you've just
literally heard me grilling
netanyahu's spokesman you call that
grilling let's go over the stuff that
was contentious with the doctor right I
asked him was what happened October the
7th a terror attack was it I believe it
to be a military offensive by various
factions of Palestinian groups not just
Hamas and many of them are not even
banned under UK law was it a terrorist
attack pardon was it a terrorist attack
have you come to an agreement about what
it means I've got the full rund down of
what terrorism is as I had at the time
you didn't you no no I had it I wanted
to know what the doctor's interpretation
of I'm not the doctor what's your
interpretation of terrorism terrorism
yeah is an act of violence targeting
children and civilians to advance the
political correct is that what Hamas did
on October the
7th is that what you think is that what
you think I'm asking you I don't believe
it was an act of terrorism no you don't
no okay even though they literally did
what you just articulated as a
definition of terrorism you have proof
that they targeted women and children
civilians specifically what's the proof
I'll tell you the proof what's the proof
you oh the GoPro videos oh you don't
think it happened oh the GoPro videos so
we like the doctor you deny no I've seen
the videos I'm a journalist I've
authenticated the videos I've seen the
videos right but show me the proof that
women and children were specifically
targeted as opposed to they were
literally burned alive hes okay where's
the proof people were beheaded proof
babies were killed name me one child one
child was beheaded name me one child
that was beheaded and I will mourn and
condemn with you I just said people were
beheaded I didn't say a child not
primary SCE objected no no so what just
to be clear to be clear like the doctor
you do not believe that anyone was
beheaded that children were killed I
clarify where I'm wrong here were were
these things
happening Israeli civilians were killed
how many I don't know Mark Greer doesn't
even know we need to First establish
they do know many we know at least 1200
people including around 400 uh soldiers
so we're assuming 800 civilians were
killed and we know at least Ked at least
another 200 odd civilians were taken
hostage right were killed by Israel how
many you a lot higher than a lot yes it
is there's no evidence of that of course
it is just look at the Nova just look at
the Nova Music Festival I look at the
burnt out cars doesn't even see this is
the problem isn't it the real reason you
want me boycotted is I'm telling the
truth and what you're doing is trying to
convince viewers and maybe your Muslim
fan base I don't know um you're trying
to convince them that what we saw
Through The Eyes of hamas's own
technology where they gloated and
boasted about what they' done didn't
happen and you want me to think and you
want me to think that even though you
articulate hang on you articulated a
description of terrorism and then said
that didn't apply to October the 7th
even though that's exactly what happened
you see I would say that's delusional I
would say it's deliberately misleading
as was the attempt to try and make me
apologize to Muslim women I've made it
abundantly clear it was a military
offensive by various factions not just
Hamas now it wasn't a military
offensive it was a terrorist attack
against predominantly civilians who were
brutalized they were tortured 7,000
children 7,000 children decapitated
Palestinian children is in terrorism is
it 7,000 children dead that heads actual
without heads again if you had Without
Limbs again if you had watched my show
last night you would have heard exactly
what my view of this was but here's the
thing you did the president of the
United States thinks they've been
indiscriminately bombing so basically
you're just going to parot wherever
Biden says is that what it is no I'm
going to say do you have a conscience of
if the president of the United States
has Intelligence of indiscriminate
bombing that is a War crime so can I
just ask you just one last thing sure
one last thing the act of Great Britain
in liberating Europe under Nazi
occupation yeah was
resistance what yes it was wasn't resist
of course it was resisting we were def
you're resisting a foreign Invader in
the continent but we were we were taking
down the Nazis okay you're taking out
well guess what according to the
Palestinians they're taking down the
Israeli occupied Colonial settlers do
you see we can just carry what do we
here the thing do we do I want to have
that conversation can we have more
respectfully in theut yes we can Wicked
but don't try and launch a boycott to
stop the one guy who's putting up more
Palestinian voices than anyone else in
the world why do you interrupt every
27.3 seconds with most your Muslim gu if
you'd watched last night for the whole
show you would have seen I didn't it
depends who the guest is and how they're
behaving have IED you today well only
when you don't answer questions which
question of have I not answered a lot
you won't even realize it go back and
watch it and you didn't answer a lot
either back and watch it but here's the
point we've reached a point of a bit
more of a civilized dial right we can do
that I would like to have that with you
just treat your Muslim guest better I do
with dignity you're not watching enough
of the interviews no I've seen AB I've
seen I've seen low key I've seen zlo
I've seen all these episodes no you're
not watching you're not you're watching
isolated shows with people who come in
and by the way are very aggressive with
me which is fine if they're going to be
aggressive with me I'll be aggressive
back if people want to be calm and
respectful as normal Bon was last night
I'll be calm and respectful back if you
chose to be like that tonight I'd have
been in the same way with you it's been
a bit of mission match bit of Miss match
come back again let's keep having the
dialogue it's
important we're here thanks for joining
us you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online run your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella Scot
son I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a FSE or a trag is the
amount of time it's taken the number of
illegal migrants currently sent by us to
Rwanda zil the amount of money it's cost
we're saying what are we saying it's
cost about 140 million £1 140 million so
far so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Cor po
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan she have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are there a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poet poetry and music for
the many I love poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to uncensor last night
the US House of Representatives voted to
launch a formal impeachment inquiry to
President Biden Republicans accus the
president of corruption and accepting
bribes other than his current role when
he was vice president between 2009 and
2017 Biden released a statement
condemning the impeachment inquiry
saying instead of doing their job on the
Urgent work needs to be done they're
choosing to waste time on this baseless
political stunt even republicans in
Congress admit is not supported by facts
well I'm joined by Fox News host and
author of Teddy and Booker are two
American icons blazed a path of racial
equality the great Brian killme Brian
great to see
you now was the great in the prompter or
did that come from the heart Pierce that
came from the heart it wasn't scripted I
just literally put it out there because
I saw your face peering at me from New
York and the word great immediately
sprang to mind I didn't have time for
the second part of that phrase but great
will do for now um Brian we're going to
come to your excellent book in a minute
it really is excellent book I want to
talk just about Joe Biden first of all
this impeachment for those who've not
followed the the intricacies of the
hunter Biden scandal summarize it very
quickly why all roads in your view lead
to the president on
this I and again this I'm so glad for
that question everyone should forget
about the hookers and the crack and the
uh and the horrible behavior of somebody
who who has uh signs of addiction uh out
of control tons of money was able to
capitalize on exist way too long you
could decide on that put that aside was
he going around from country to Country
Kazakhstan China Ukraine yes yes and yes
was he talking to the rich
woman in Russia yes was he doing
business with him yes what was his
business it was the influence and
leverage his dad had in Washington for
being there since his late 20s this guy
was vice president United States
formative chairman of Foreign Relations
when he was in the Senate it looked like
he was queuing up to run for president
we know he would do that and win and all
people wanted to find out is was he in
fact compromised shouldn't you just
become come clean and say like we know
Don Donald Trump's got a hotel in Turkey
you might not like that he's got a
building on 57th Street you might not
like that he's got influences in
Scotland you might not like that but we
knew what we were voting for all people
wanted to know is what were you doing
with this country and will that affect
your foreign policy at all instead you
got denials if you tweeted that they'd
passively uh suppress your social media
they destroyed the New York Post for six
weeks or excuse me for uh for two weeks
for quite a long time for different
writers if you brought this up or had
proof and had some questions about these
overseas business dealings so now we
find out the president United States now
said I had nothing to do with it then he
said I knew about it now yesterday we
find out or this week we learn that he
said my dad did not benefit financially
from my business dealings excuse me you
are evolving this Story in real time and
I think it's important for people to
know before they vote is their president
compromised and why haven't they as he
told the truth since 2020 yeah it all
stinks let's listen to a bit of Hunter
Biden yesterday we hadn't heard from him
for quite a while listen to this and in
the ad depths of my addiction I was
extremely irresponsible with my
finances but to suggest that is grounds
for an impeachment inquiry is beyond the
Absurd it's
Shameless there is no evidence to
support the allegations that my father
was financially involved in my business
because it did not happen do you not
thinking uh Brian if you swapped Hunter
Biden for Donald Trump Jr right and this
was about Trump and the trumps can you
imagine anyone who's currently defending
Hunter and Joe Biden about this
defending the trumps absolutely not they
would be baying for
blood there's no question I mean
39-year-old Eric Trump who's running the
company say he's been subpoenaed more
than anybody he knows he doesn't drink
he doesn't smoke he goes home and plays
with his kids kids tries to run the
company the best he can been subpoena
over business practic that took place
even before he was uh he was the
Executive Vice President of the company
you know the key thing I always come
back to on this um other than the
suppression of the laptop story which
was a complete disgrace the way the New
York Post was was basically
banned vaporized before the last
election to stop uh Joe Biden
potentially losing over that Scandal but
if you think about just one fact that
Hunter Biden was put on the board of a
company called barisma Energy company in
Ukraine despite having absolutely zero
experience of anything in that sector
whatsoever he's put on the board and
earning I think was like $100,000 a a
month or something crazy like a million
a year I mean SE obscene amounts of
money with zero expertise and who
happens to have the responsibility for
Ukraine and the administration of Barack
Obama is father I mean just that fact
alone stinks to high
heaven it does and it was Joe Biden's
decision after Crimea was taken the dbas
region was infiltrated to only give the
ukrainians blankets and MREs instead of
javelins that we all know would have
turned the the Russians around do you
know and you know this because you like
me think this is a worthy cause for the
West do you know that they've taken out
over 300,000 Russian troops 90% of the
original invading Army is now dead or
casualties of the war you wonder if Joe
Biden I just like to know this were you
compromised at all about a deal you made
with a the wife of a Russian mayor in
order to two weeks later after this
meeting next thing you know there's an
invasion I would just like to know if
your meeting had anything to do with
that why is that a bad question to ask
why can't we follow that trail yeah I
think there's so many unanswered
questions and this this protestation of
total innocence from the whole Biden
family is ridiculous um let's turn
quickly to your book Brian Teddy and
Booker had two American icons blazed a
path of racial equality it's a
fascinating story based around 1901
president Theodore Roosevelt of course
is at the White House and he welcomed
the country's most visible black man
civil rights activist and educator
Booker T Washington into his circle of
counselors at the White House it was 30
years I believe after that before
another black man was was greeted that
way at the White House so it
extraordinary in two ways one that it
happened when it did and two that it
didn't happen again for 30 years tell me
what motivated you to write the
book you know what's so funny is that no
one's ever pointed that out that nothing
happened after that except for Pierce
Morgan because I know you always think
what's next so what what happened is if
you I read Up From Slavery Booker T
Washington's book and when you were born
a slave you don't have shoes and slept
on the floor every day lucky to have one
meal a day and at 9 years old you
remember being called to the Main's
house on a plantation and remembers here
hearing from a Union soldier that you're
free and you from that moment become
eventually become one of the most
influential men in America known around
the world treated as a celebrity when he
went through the UK and throughout
Europe you got my attention and I
started researching everything he wrote
and all he wanted to do was spread this
horrible thing called education he
thought education was a great equalizer
it's an amazing story it's a great book
such an interesting different kind of
subject matter and one that's not really
been properly written about so I commend
you Brian I also commend you on being
the single hardest working man in world
news fact man woman nonbinary you take
your gender uh you are it you are the
hardest person in terms of work rate
I've ever encountered in World
television so the fact you found me a
fragment of your day to come on
uncensored is a matter of great personal
joy for
me wow uh am I your favorite at Fox I
asked your whole staff I could not get a
commitment you know what
as your favorite you are my favorite Fox
Talent who's on my show right now and I
will look forward to seeing you in New
York very soon Brian and Before I Let
You Go Merry Christmas let me be the
first to wish you a Merry
Christmas uh thanks so much Pierce
congratulations on the success of your
shows heard around the world and I I
love being on it thanks so much great to
see you Brian all the very
[Music]
best
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and Rich she soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster ETS attached to it certainly
the tone has shifted in terms of what
Rashi sunak has done the question now is
what he does next the police of pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a f or a
tragedy talk TB has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for sadique Khan we're
not stopping until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC Mouse
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film did